vous avez été plus de 16000 à voter pour
votre courts métrages préférés sur ma
chaîne voici les résultats j'ai
l'impression d'être un présentateur
météo en troisième et quatrième position
presque à ex-aequo la cartouche réalisé
par théodore monod c'est ma déclaration
d'amour pour les petites chaînes youtube
et pour le gaming finalement je sais pas
si vous savez mais après le générique on
voit carlito hudgens a et l'autre moi
qui m'ont court métrage le plus
personnel celui qui me ressemblent plus
dans lequel je me suis le plus investi
donc j'en suis le plus fier finalement
en deuxième position technophobes mon
tout premier court métrage sur ma chaîne
youtube réalisé par théodore monod ce
court métrage a une place particulière
dans mon coeur parce que ça a été le
début de plein d'autres histoires de
plein d'autres projets donc je suis très
fier qu'il soit là et votre courts
métrages préférés sur ma chaîne youtube
et minori qui a été tournée au japon
réalisé par françois descraques c'est le
court métrage qui m'a donné le plus de
bons souvenirs j'adore leur visionner
écouter les musiques voilà c'est votre
courts métrages préférés merci pour tous
vos votes pour tout votre soutien aussi
au quotidien et je vous dis à très vite
pour des nouvelles fictions